now while the left is losing it Aldean's
fans they are standing strongly behind
him our team spoke to some of them
outside of his concert in Ohio tonight
by the way the concert ended up being
canceled uh sadly there was a tornado
watch warning going on right around
where the stadium was I hope everyone
got home safe anyway take a look
but I'm actually sick of is the woke
left's canceling of Everything the song
is just the next step in that process
that's going on and it's terrible it's
changing the country that we lived in I
think that people that are all up in
arms about it haven't actually watched
the video they haven't actually listened
to the lyrics and people are projecting
people are projecting what they think
into something about a small town you
know what if you've ever lived in a
small town you know we take care of our
own period Well I think personally uh
with him uh he's just playing country
music he didn't try to do anything to
upset people it's just playing country
music why aren't we looking at some of
the other uh lyrics that some of the
other genres
correspond to what Jason Aldean said I
think it's absolutely ridiculous
honestly I think he should be able to do
and say exactly what he thinks and what
he wants I think this whole world needs
to take A New Perspective upon this
whole situation I think if if people um
if people on a certain side of the
spectrum like something they're going to
dislike it it doesn't matter what it is
so since we like it they don't hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else